We've seen now that if the graph of a function doesn't have any breaks in it,
then the curve is going to pass through all the y values that lie between the y
value of the starting point and the y value of the ending point of whatever
region of the graph that we're looking at. This concept has a special name.
It's called the intermediate value theorem. Now, let's say that all we know
about the two end points of this curve, which I've now labeled A and B, is that
the y-coordinate of point A is a negative. And the y-coordinate of point B is
positive. If that's the case, then what is the one value of y that we know the
curve has to pass through between point A and point B? There's only one that we
can be completely sure of. Think carefully about this.